back-to-back ok I'm playing am Sherlock
again and according to them motto I'm
going for a king-size fianchetto yeah we
got an English opening here symmetrical
English a5 that's early maybe switch to
this setup yeah he went from the
so-called von Vinick set up with see 585
which is a very reliable way to turn
play with both colors actually this can
also be played with white gassy 44 um I
have made sure to get d5 occupied and
I'm angling for um before him is there a
reason not to play before now and I
don't think so so let's do it sometimes
they are tactical issues like
unprotected c3 night or something like
that it might be oh yeah ok so it was
maybe a bit untimely more advanced okc
takes night before Bishop e3 yeah I have
some play down I have some play so do a
chick I didn't think a tick with the
pawn I didn't didn't really see that
before head but it's interesting here
this position is quite interesting if
you go slide a six to keep the material
I have some play against d6 for example
so
definitely a label a playable position I
guess what is he doing maybe still 96 I
mean now I wonder if rook b6 is a more
or if this is just just not very
harmonious I yes night c8 actually I
that that's a pretty simple reply to
that so maybe he I am so what now I can
go Queen a form maybe yeah maybe just
that we might go p6 just be six
okay I was thinking maybe just before
now but even 97's a move yeah I think I
had to get out of this pin the Queen on
a forum for 97 let's do that if he moves
to see 89 now I can take the six and one
night c5 I have deform so this is this
is some compensation not sure if it is
enough but it is some compensation yeah
so let's go D for its not much else
there
so Quincy six you cannot take that so it
looks indict look sorry that looks
annoying at least I'll take it ja rupee
one is also strong who's taking away
squares I am a b97 oh maybe he can go 90
sound I can take bishop age three maybe
mmm interesting that working one was i
played this too quickly I should have
considered that a little bit more
yeah if I don't don't want to go back I
can take b6 of course nights 95
let's see five that's five is annoying
but actually maybe I can even give away
the Queen then or is that is set to
weird I it is rather interesting
probably not enough can I go somewhere
else coss look b5 I would still I should
take them I already thought for too long
about that night see if I can also just
take a five it's really nothing wrong
with that I was thinking about let's say
night c5 dc5 if this is some kind of
idea but it's as I said totally totally
unnecessary to do it okay so he's
looking at deform bishop age three maybe
let's do that for the pin
yeah right the game before I lost a very
very nice position I don't want to lose
again if possible against the same
player what about now can I can I give
the Queen now or is this again this is
insane it probably is insane so let's
just take him I'm always fascinated by
by things like those Queen sacrifices
and try to make it work but non non
fancy moves usually are better like here
just take that if he goes to d3 work t1
it's not clear where the night is going
and if he just goes back to be seven
what was the point of it all
here I don't know we're here
it's 93 move no one and 94 minimal from
the northern 92 is not known
what is my next move if you play
something something slow probably the
Queen out of that strange long diagonal
I don't know where exactly it is taking
lots of time oh wow can I not take these
six now why not let's do that come on i
cannot time my question every move okay
I'm here maybe queen's eggs I don't know
it's may be easier okay so I'm probably
getting my black resign getting my
revenge there for the for the loss yeah
trickier I really blundered blundered
that here with before but it seemed to
give pretty decent compensation this
scenario here that that looks quite
interesting and I'm not sure maybe you
should play something that group c 8 i'm
not i'm not i'm unsure about that maybe
my compensation is really quite good
after this so it looks very very nice
very attractive this position for white
okay the engine is giving Queen d2 yeah
that's probably better not not going
into this pin but but just go here and
this one that is really nice you know
now all my pieces are active and I have
this idea to infiltrate with the rook
also d for making this night look a bit
silly yeah that's even better than then
what I did but I quickly got out of the
pin yeah yeah let's just just a very
nice position rook rook e1 is probably
not the best well okay a computer likes
it yeah well here i'm just taking pawns
i just i just take far too long for that
yeah i don't i don't really know I have
to take on b6 anyway and just very
unpractical sometimes
computer agrees with all the moves but I
just take too long to play them Queen
the queen bee seven just loses the house
I wasn't completely sure what to do if
he plays on I know a slowish booth but
like yeah but maybe I can just play play
this yeah this seems to be possible hmm
yeah that's possible again it just loses
loses everything yeah I'm a rook up at
the end of it yeah okay that was nice
Goodwin and a good revenge game against
against this guy thanks for watching